well suppose it's time for one more
martini
[Applause]
[Music]
no time to die what will be supposedly I
say supposedly I'm pretty confident in
this one but we've also heard this
before the last outing of Daniel Craig
as James Bond double-oh-seven
that was supposedly the case for Spectre
but they did bring him back for one more
I really do think he's probably done
this time though so this trailer dropped
and I'll admit I was initially kind of a
little annoyed because trailers like
they're dropping at a rate that I
usually don't see outside of like around
major calm economy we stopped um I need
a break
but yeah I do want to talk about this
one so it looks really good and I said I
mean visually I mean it looks great the
shots are great the stunts look great
it looks very practical I'm sure there's
some CGI enhancement but what I've
always appreciated about the Daniel
Craig era of James Bond as they go for
they actually doing all the stunts which
is one of the really good things about
this this era of James Bond I mean
there's one of the good things about
James Bond as a franchise in general but
it has had its times where it you know
it didn't do it as well or as much but
that they've really nailed that and
Craig looked I was worried that he was
gonna look asleep or uninvested knowing
how very firmly he said he would not do
another after Spectre I think something
along the lines of I would rather I
would rather break this glass and slit
my wrists so I did kind of worry that
him coming back for one more after being
so vehemently against the idea that it
was he
was gonna give it up or give a
performance that made it clear he was
just here for the paycheck but it
doesn't look like that it looks like he
is invested putting in the effort
putting in the work which is good um the
you know this does look good it looks
fine he's got the banter going you know
little moment he has with qj-- ever
writes back his felix leiter down for
that and yeah there's there's a lot that
I can see this go that looks cool
problem is there was a lot in the lead
up to Spectre that looked cool and there
was a lot even in the film that looked
cool it was still a garbage fire of a
movie I didn't like it at the time I saw
it has soured for me over time whatever
there was I had nice to say about it
there isn't much left and at this point
the Daniel Craig era is soon burnt
consistent when they're good they're
great when and when they're good we get
Casino Royale which I actually think is
slightly overrated but is still really
good and we get Skyfall which I love but
then we also get Quantum of Solace which
we seem to have collectively as a
culture just decided we're going to
pretend never happened and then there's
Spectre which unfortunately I can't
pretend it didn't happen because it's
tying in very directly with this one on
a number of levels
and that's another thing that makes me
nervous aside from the precedent because
if I were a more superstitious person
and tried to adopt something similar to
the Star Trek supposed Star Trek film
thing where only the the even numbers
were good and it seems like the Dan
Craig era only the odd numbers were good
the first one was good the third one was
good oh maybe the fifth one will be good
except like I said it's tying in
directly to Spectre inspector was not
good and as much as I I'll admit you
shouldn't like throw the baby out in the
battle with the bathwater in terms of
elements like Blofeld certainly
especially he's a big enough part of the
history of this franchise that uh and
Christoph Waltz is a good enough actor
that you don't completely give up on
that
but just even having the connection and
because his performance was fine but I
hated how they did Blofeld like from a
writing narrative perspective motivation
for him especially high a did it so much
so I'm not thrilled at the idea of them
bringing Blofeld back and doing anything
without what throws me off a lot more
though it makes me a lot more worried is
they're bringing back the love interest
usually seems like a strong term to use
with James Bond but they're bringing
back the you know the girl he ended up
with at the end of Spectre and it looks
like she's driving a lot of the plot
like her secrets and they're at least
how the trailers cut which you know
asterisks and allowance can't always be
deceptive a trailer can always be cut to
imply things that are not in fact the
case or make it look like this might be
what's going on but that's not really it
editing can change absolutely everything
so I I'm allowing for that but also
realize I'm I can only judge what I've
seen what I've seen is the trailer I'm
gonna take it at face value until I have
a reason to not do that so they're
making it look like he's really
connected with this woman there's a
couple of lines and like reaction shots
or whatever to make it seem like he's
really hung up on her like he really
sunk his heart into her I don't like
that I'm not gonna say you can't do that
with bond but they did it with this bond
they did it with Vesper Lynd back in
Casino Royale and it made a lot of sense
there because that was this bond
starting out and it really kind of makes
it sets the ground for him to be the
bomb were a little bit more familiar
with who doesn't get super emotionally
invested he can get angry but he doesn't
he doesn't give his heart away because
we got to see in Casino Royale how badly
it went for him the one time he did that
so the idea of having him you know get
there again the thing is like if these
stories in
if bond as a franchisee was about a
character journey and an art for James
Bond as a character then it wouldn't
bother me I'd be like oh look at that
he's he's healed enough that he's
willing to get with a you know another
person and put his heart out there again
but that sub what James Bond is James
Bond suffers when it's more about the
man than his work it should be about
what he does and how cool he is doing it
when you try and make it too much about
the character and his inner workings or
his personal journey
honestly you kind of lose the thread a
little bit about what's great about bond
you know you can still make it personal
Skyfall pulled that off and you know the
tail end of Casino Royale pulled that
off but you know they also went too far
with Quantum of Solace with basically
his entire thing being a revenge
motivation which is a weird motivation
for a guy who's it's literally his job
to kill people you don't have to give
him a revenge motivation in order to set
him on the path to kill a lot of people
that wasn't the only problem with that
movie that was just Bradley put together
film with a half-baked script but and
then you know we get to Spectre and they
try and make it more about him and his
and his history and his connections was
with Blofeld which were dumb so I I like
it when somebody can get under bonds
skin a little bit it's actually one of
the reasons I consider the world's is
not enough to be kind of underrated but
when there's a difference between having
a character kind of get to him on a
personal level and having the film
depend on being invested in him as a
character with a journey as opposed to a
character who's just cool and awesome
and we get to enjoy this so that worries
me because I think in general Bond films
suffer when they're more about him as a
character than about how cool and
awesome it is to just see what he does
so that's another reason for me to worry
and I I don't know if they know what
Bond
is anymore the thing is as much as there
have been great entries in the Daniel
Craig era of bond it really does seem
like they reinvent it almost film for
film you know Casino Royale casino
royale is actually kind of a weird
hybrid in some ways but you can see the
impact of things like save the Jason
Bourne films in things like the fight
choreography and that was taken even to
a further extreme with Quantum of Solace
because they tried to do the handheld
and heavy cutting but they failed very
badly at it I mean I would argue Paul
Greengrass barely is able to pull that
off and that movie absolutely wasn't and
then Skyfall became a little bit more
meta and a little bit more legacy sort
of thing which is you know was kind of
becoming more of a thing at that time as
you know things like superheroes were
becoming bigger and a lot of those
stories are about are about legacy and
and you know leaving in what we leave
behind and things like that so that's
sort of again fit into what was the
modern milieu I don't know why I decided
to actually try and say that word with
the French pronunciation I probably
butchered it but anyways and then we get
to Spectre where they tried I think they
didn't know what modern thing to ape
with Spectre and so they tried to bring
back a bunch of elements from classic
without understanding why they worked at
the time that they did and then they're
just in there like a checklist and they
don't function worth a day at all with
the really horrible stupid at this point
very cliche I am the architect of all
your pain stupid friggin twist with
Blofeld which is dumb and I hate it it's
not even new but it's been very popular
lately in the last decade or so with
some of these big franchises be they on
TV or film and I hate it
I'll always hate that but I don't think
you can say that there's a uniform feel
to be Daniel Craig era this
feel to his bond his portrayal is
consistent I mean the films as a whole
and so that leaves me in a position
where I don't really know what to expect
of this because say what you will about
the other eras of James Bond whether you
like them or don't they have a
consistent flavor to them they have a
consistent feel to them even if they end
up at you know in an end of a spectrum
where it doesn't work anymore which
ultimately happened with pretty much all
of them sooner or later you know as much
as I will defend most of the Pierce
Brosnan movies they did get silly or
ancillary ants and sillier as they went
on you know just to the point that ya
die another day was ridiculous and in a
way that wasn't quite working anymore
but it did still feel organically of the
same era the feel of all the the Craig
films are is very very different which
means I look at this trailer and go that
looks cool but I don't know what to
expect from this thing I still intend to
see it because when Bond films are good
they're really good and in a way that is
it's actually hard to find in other
franchises but I feel like hitting the
sweet spot has really become a moving
target in recent years and the severe
unevenness of this franchise I'm gonna
be nervous and I and honestly no matter
what the trailer is even if the trailer
didn't have some of the elements and
things and indicators that had me
worried even if the trailer looked
amazing on every level I had nothing to
complain about what I saw in the trailer
I would still be nervous just given the
track record of this franchise you know
when with Craig and the roles and again
the unevenness not his fault but it's
still the Daniel Craig era so his name
get slapped on it apologies to the man
but that's James Bond no time to die the
trailer what you think about the trailer
are you excited for the movie was the
trailer enough to get you excited are
you massive
Oh jackass like me and you're still
nervous even though the trailer was
honestly pretty good whatever your
thoughts are drops on me on the comments
let's talk about it stuff to do as well
I have a patreon that is greatly
immensely appreciated if you're able to
support me on that failing that like
subscribe share this video that helps me
out as well and it appeases the
algorithm other stuff to do is well
links below for merch and my social
media and then my peel boxes down there
holidays are coming up if you're if you
want feel like sending me something I
don't know why people do but they do I
appreciate it but whatever you also
don't have to do any of it because at
the end of the day you're the council
and I'm just running the meetings so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]